So now you've seen how diverse Udacity students are. They come from all over the
world, I think, over 146 countries actually. What else do we want to know about
Udacity students? Ron, Shawn, and I think that people should be life-long
learners, and a lot of our students value learning beyond high school and
college. And then other students want to get head start on things that they wont
learn for another few years. As a result, we get students as young as 13 and as
old as 85. Just like how we analyzed countries students are from, how about we
analyze their ages? So here's a sample of student ages, and again we have 50.
How can we analize this data the same way we analyzed the country data? So
instead of having country in the frequency data, we have age. How can we create
this table? How many rows would you have? Would you need 50, one for each
student in the sample, or maybe 66 rows, one for each age from 10 years to 75
years? 8 to 10 rows because that's just easiest to understand? It depends on how
you group the data, or 2 rows, one for over 50 years old and one for under 50
years old.